night and day not day and night the pics
are short about you know racism but a
spy movie
[Music]
okay so surprisingly night and day was
really fun in that really cool spy movie
kind of way at first alright so as we
all saw in the trailer Tom Cruise meets
Cameron Diaz in an airport and they get
on the plane together and they talk he's
a nice guy they like each other turns
out of course he's a super spy all those
great guys are and now he needs to keep
Cameron Diaz out of trouble or out of
harm's way one of the two or both
ultimately people are coming after her
because they want Tom Cruise because Tom
Cruise has this little trinket that they
want that's pretty much the gist of it
so from there the movie pretty much
feels like what would happen if James
Bond and burn out went splat and had a
kid with Grand Theft Auto yeah that
sounds awesome
and it was awesome at first first off I
really like Tom Cruise's character when
he's in spy mode he is badass he's
pretty much like what every guy thinks
they would be like in that situation we
all think that when the bullets start
flying we're gonna be like just be cool
I got this this isn't even me like
pretending that I have a gun the finger
gun yeah this kills Chuck Norris runs
from this finger game that's a fact but
in reality I mean I'm watching Tom
Cruise and I'm like I totally hang out
with that guy in real life he's awesome
he's like what would happen if Jerry
Maguire met that crazy guy who was
jumping on Oprah's couch cuz he was
banging the chick from Dawson's Creek oh
[ __ ] that was him that make sense then I
mean he and Cameron Diaz had chemistry
the movie was looking good but from
there you're watching it you realize
that the second half of the movie is
nowhere near as cool as the first half I
mean the movie just became all over the
place in the transition in between
locations was annoying and here's how
they did it every time the movie would
change between this country in this
country Cameron Diaz would get knocked
out and the screen would go black then
she'd wake up in the new country like a
day would pass and usually she got
knocked out right before an action
sequence well we don't get to see it the
next thing we see she's waking up the
action sequence happened and that's that
yeah it was annoying and dumb I mean
after it happens the first time you roll
with it but after a few times it gets
annoying and then it's like the writers
just got lazy with it like there's this
scene where this this stealth fighter
this thing is like super advanced like
that stealth fighter from that shitty
stealth movie this thing is shooting
Rockets app and this thing looks like a
predator ship and they go to this shitty
little helicopter this thing has no shot
at getting no matter they're alive and
right before they get into their little
$10 helicopter to ward off the sci-fi
Chan
stealth fighter Tom Cruise knocks out
Cameron Diaz the screen goes black when
it comes back there in another country
and they're fine
I for one do not believe that I'm alone
when I say I would like to have seen how
they accomplish that I mean it's like
the writers didn't know how to write
them out of that pickle so they're like
well the screen will just go black and
they wake up somewhere else
or I'm done in fact let's do that a few
times I mean it's kind of like they were
trying to go for that feeling you get
when you go to a restaurant then you get
up to go take a piss and then you come
back and your foods waiting for you and
you don't question it it's just cool
that you didn't lose time so you just
dig in only it didn't feel like that I
just wanted answers so the first half
was really cool it was good it was
exciting it didn't take yourself too
seriously Tom Cruise was awesome but the
last half was sloppy I went from a cool
spy movie to a lazy spy movie as lazy
location changes rushed scenes and like
missing action sequences here it is go
to the movie theater and offer them half
the ticket price to watch half the movie
that seems fair I'd do that but if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more than click right here to see
more passing out for a location change
you couldn't do the Indiana Jones you
couldn't have the mat come up with the
red line showing worried I mean that
works you couldn't just start wrecking
their transport them yeah